[Music]
okay here we go got some news here in
unlikely reunion news submitted by just
like geo the internet healthy homeless
man find his stolen pet rat at what
point okay so I got a bunny right um
just moved into a spot he's like oh yeah
I got a I got a mouse named peanut comes
by eats at a bird feeder I'm like cool
dude sounds awesome a couple days later
well I got another another Mouse you
know let's call it sandy or whatever the
[ __ ] he called his mouth my okay dude
he's like now you got two mice at what
point does it go from pet mice to rat
infestation when you put them in a cage
or not so for him he had a [ __ ] rat
infestation for me I had [ __ ] pets
[ __ ] pets yeah but like how many
exactly three that sounds like an
infestation it was a party that was a
party of three that you know yeah yeah
yeah
that's it the rest are infested in your
walls which like gives us a type of cage
what's the average lifespan of a rat
well I had feeder rats my it's about
like two to three years five if you're
crazy the rats what's that
the ones you feed to like snakes and
stuff and you kept them as pets yeah
it's a long story
cuz I have a kind heart okay what about
the snakes Anita Eko there's the other
that's their problem
yeah [ __ ] them yeah - snake we have to
go buy another rat cuz we had the snake
and then she rescues one rat so
gotcha what happened to that snake it
doesn't matter we can get okay now that
week now that we understand the basic
ins outs of RIP infestation versus pet
cat if it's in a cage or not that's
basically that's the basic world literal
cage or like a band okay homeless man
wait so how does this guy even have a
pet rat he's homeless aren't there like
a lot of infestation I'm picturing like
he went to the pet store and bought a
rat and he's just been putting it in his
pocket and he kicks it in his pocket he
gives it to you I've never had a rat
infestation I've had mouse mice or
whatever they came and visited my rat
they tried to [ __ ] rat I had a rat in
the cage they would come out and try to
[ __ ] it all night that's a smashing
pumpkin [ __ ] each other
yeah Radek agent myself I got a rat in a
cage
the mice trying to [ __ ] it
we had like 12 of them it was crazy I
thought it was only one but there was 12
so I'm saying there's always more and
that's why pets pet rats are not your
pets they're just data infest yes well
this one doesn't and patate oh all right
yeah so Chris he's homeless in the
streets of Sydney and he had his pet rat
named Lucy who he got when Lucy was like
a little tiny baby from a couple that
passed by I'm like hey you want this
[ __ ] homeless people love rats
you want your disease-ridden small road
ahead almost man Kristen Lucy always
picturing a real ratatouille I know but
then Chris went inside to use a restroom
Oh Lucy out the word ugh all that soup
no it's just a jacket with it hey why
did he take the [ __ ] rat in the
bathroom with those well he could have
put into this jacket I agree with well
he's almost got Candida this is like a
very Canadian sort of homeless man yeah
I was picturing a real bomb the Canada
of the sea of the sea yeah - Australia
all right so then when he went inside -
you go to his restroom that's when
somewhat this lady walked by and saw
Lucy there all by herself and she
thought that Lucy needed her help and so
she rescued Lucy she stole him don't
Lizzy I like how people come up with
their own narratives wait who rescues
rats you're supposed to kill it here bro
we have a very a line here yeah some
people on the rats infesting and they're
not they're not really that your pet
other people rescuing
homeless rats
rats rats smart it's a [ __ ] guinea
pig yeah I love that
and how is he dressed the same in the
rat and [ __ ] we know that's just light
hot doesn't light so then Chris oh
here's another oh she's so cute
and then so Chris he was heartbroken and
very worried so he posed one looks
worried he posted a sign here that says
what is my pet rat I would die laughing
if I saw that [ __ ] said my pet rat Lucy
was stolen on Saturday Lucy is black and
white with a bite of brown Chris it
sounds like a joke almost wait what does
that mean it's just he's just sharing
the facts well I guess by saying that
she you know like call me at one eight
hundred I'm homeless
yeah you can't contact him but he should
have been like if you see her can you
please bring her back to me I think it's
implied by saying it was stolen right so
then so then that's what a lot of people
because he usually stays in one spot so
a lot of people walk by there often they
already know him and Lucy and like
sometimes people will stop in my pet
Lucy so he was very well known in this
area mr. rat man they're very there's
more my rat was like that color and then
I would have I'm okay justice all on my
shoulder and [ __ ] and [ __ ] would [ __ ]
aren't usual just relax
so everybody is rats use the one that's
the ha - enough no I had plenty of rats
that just I didn't choose him as pets Oh
subway rats apartment rats all kinds of
rats I grew up a lot of right a lot of
rats right
no no disillusions here they're not them
they're not my pets all my friends we
did not get along
maybe the street rats are different they
have like patches missing and they just
have like one eye and they're just ready
to fight yeah definitely good friends
[ __ ] they're like the mob so what's the
opposite of a street rat they're not
well-fed house right the house right
okay so then with current like someone
saw him and then post it on Facebook
trying to ask anyone like oh can you
guys help help Chris find Lucy and
finally they were able to be reunited
and here's a video of that moment
wait the cops the cops back everyone got
involved oh my god
okay wait Lucy you did nothing
who's blind eye does he know he smells a
plague on them kisses that's a
well-dressed home [ __ ] that dude thank
you very much everybody
you know she's miss make too late it
looks like a squirrel dog you know I
think the biggest difference is if that
rat didn't had that hairless tail people
would like them more didn't be a
squirrel yeah it was just further that's
where you grab them by just fancy rats
this is how it is what's wrong with the
ill cuz they're just like it looks like
a worm well it's like that hairless
[ __ ] cat yeah those are wild yeah I'm
not the one that no one likes except for
Kat Von D ha ha ha like a [ __ ] living
scrotum
it's a [ __ ] testicle something fishy
about that about what the whole thing is
a little too in love with that rat a
little too nicely you you know looking
like Dumbledore kind of sitting and it's
like with this nicely dressed rat look
like a guinea pig in this Canada of the
sea and the police come and help out and
it got the rat bagging no now it seems
like a seems like a stage bit for
Instagram no this is Australia people
are so nice and polite in Australia yes
a Canada of the sea yeah right even the
homeless people aren't homeless she
spends too much dress so someone started
a GoFundMe for him everybody's a [ __ ]
GoFundMe what's $2,000 gonna do to get
you a rat back so he they raise the 2002
you were supposed to look at her screen
yeah but what is mm like a private
investigator or something no so the goal
was $1,000 just like help Chris and Lucy
just buy enough cheese to like lay
cheese sprinkle sort of rattles back to
him well he'll have enough rest there's
a lot of comments and hearsay
like hey so apparently Chris hasn't
received any of this money as of yet I'm
just wondering when it will get to him
because remember that hole oh yeah the
last $20 given for the gas so now people
are skeptical like people help me home
listen on giving them money oh how was
he gonna get it he doesn't have a
computer or phone what is it like a
GoFundMe 18 they're almost people go up
to him like this versus your rad cash
right you didn't set it up how do you
get your money so someone has to deliver
him like a stack of money yeah yeah was
the woman that posted on Facebook to
help Chris find Lucy
no that is kind of sketch though cuz if
you naughty yeah if you're just a
stranger and you're like here's a here's
a foundation for rap man and then like
you put in all this money but she
doesn't even know him or whatever she
just jumps on the news and tries to do
that that's a good scam yeah there's a
lot of a lot of rats in this narrative
he started off kind of go and that's
[ __ ] up and then ended that sense is
[ __ ] inspired and motivated we should
talk later about this let's just go on
like looking for missing pets and stuff
fun news forum and just collect all the
cash that people just dump it pets
that's a nice little racket yeah oh yeah
[ __ ] well the homeless man guy got you
know that they got caught because they
were working together the homeless man
and the couple so at first man it was
crazy cuz it first came out like a
roller coaster of us he got [ __ ] over
because he gave him gas and then this
[ __ ] happened and he was living behind
back home I guess in the backyard and
[ __ ] and he didn't get any of the money
and then he did but he didn't get as
much as he wanted to and all this [ __ ]
and at the end of it all it was all
conspired together he was working with
them for this whole story
everything was he really homeless I
don't know about that not just Canadian
yeah yeah yeah no he looked really good
this guy at least actually even very
worried and sexy I don't know why rats
get a bad rap because of the plague and
Disney you know I know why I know
yeah I know I know the water gets all
right I get it I get it but they're
really smart and they're really clean
animals
how come hamsters don't [ __ ] invade
your home and [ __ ] because they're done
is fun I still don't know what a hamster
is or like a guinea pig
what all are they I know guinea pigs are
like what South America know something
from Guinea yeah I don't know where
hamsters come from there's no day me
yeah it's like do you ever see a wild
hamster no they're always looking at a
ball somewhere and where corn flakes are
and do they come from hand no hmm why
they call hamsters I think like maybe
you really like him
oh that guy's a hamster
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]